vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrter Herr
Staatssekretär sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren hier auf der Besuchergalerie
und vor den
Bildschirmen wie geht's
Ihnen wie geht's Ihnen wenn Sie die
Bilder sehen die wir alltäglich aus dem
Krieg der Ukraine mitnehmen müssen wie
geht ihen wenn wir die furchtbaren
Bilder sehen seit dem
Terroranschlag der
Heras wie geht's ihnen allen
damit wie glücklich können wir uns alle
schätzen dass wir in Frieden in Freiheit
in Sicherheit leben können in einer
Demokratie leben
können
wie
selbstverständlich betrachten wir das
und wie selbstverständlich haben wir das
auch in der Vergangenheit
gesehen und
daher brauchen wir nicht so sehr
zurückschauen aus welchen Gründen man
das Bundesheer so lange vernachlässigt
hat es hat natürlich auch damit zu tun
dass sich geopolitisch alles verändert
und
und das nicht zum
besseren das was ihnen allen aber jedem
einzelnen und jeder einzelnen von ihnen
gelungen ist ist das was S die letzten
Jahre erleben wo ich jedes Jahr hier
stehe und ihnen sehr gete Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete ein Dankeschön sage
dass wir erkannt haben wie wichtig die
militärische Landesverteidigung ist wie
wichtig jede Investition in unser
österreichisches Bundesheer ist und so
stehe ich auch Heer wieder vor ihnen wir
können das Budget um
21% erhöhen wir sind damit auf über 4
Milliarden eine Schallgrenze die wir
überschritten haben allein für den
Investitionsbereich ist es ein Plus von
66%. und W geklatscht wird dann gebührt
dieser Applaus ja Ihnen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren weil sie sind es die
dieses Budget beschließen wir haben es
auch geschafft im Bereich der Sicherheit
nicht die Parteipolitik walten zu lassen
das war spürbar in jedem unserer
Ausschüsse das war auch spürbar im
letzten Budgetausschuss und ich halte
das auch für unabdingbar notwendig in
einer Zeit die geprägt ist von Krisen
dass wir uns jetzt darüber unterhalten
wie wir das österreichische Bundesheer
zu einer modernen Armee machen wo wir
investieren werden das ist ganz klar wir
haben einen Aufbauplan der geht bis zum
Jahr
2032 und darüber hinaus er geht über die
Legislaturperiode hinaus auch das haben
sie sehr gehrte Damen und Herren
Abgeordneten hier im Plenum beschlossen
die Bereiche in die wir investi
werden beginnen vom wichtigsten von
unseren Soldatinnen und Soldaten denen
wir in der Vergangenheit nicht die
entsprechende Wertschätzung auch gegeben
haben in sie werden wir investieren in
die neuen Uniformen in die entsprechende
Bewaffnung in moderne
Kommunikationsmittel und wenn ich von
den Soldatinnen und Soldaten spreche
dann dürfen wir auch die Basis nicht
vergessen das sind unsere grundwerdiener
und da waren es auch Sie die dafür
gesorgt haben wir gemeinsam die dafür
gesorgt haben dass das Sold für die
grundwerdiiner endlich nach 10 Jahren
erhöht
wird wir investieren in die Mobilität es
ist angesprochen worden von ihnen 36 neu
Hubschrauber die Nachfolge für unser
transportfugzeug eine Nachfolge auch für
die jettrainer die Modernisierung
unserer Panzertruppe unsere pantur die
so viel auch an österreichischer wert
Schöpfung mitbringen absolut neuwertige
LKW flotten die wir haben allein das
letzte Paket
850 LKWs damit wir all den
Herausforderungen auch begegnen
können und der ganz wichtige Bereich der
Kasernen in die wir investieren wo wir
schon so vieles zustande gebracht haben
nachhaltig auch zu bauen die Mannschaft
Unterkünfte wieder auf Vordermann zu
bringen auch das ist auf einem sehr
guten Weg und ein Dankeschön an sie alle
die immer wieder auch dabei sind wenn
wir einen spartenstich und dann auch die
Eröffnung feiern
können das ist das eine dass wir zu
investieren haben das andere ist wer tut
es das sind die Soldatinnen und die
Soldaten wer ist verantwortlich dafür
dass wir auch wissen was es zu
verteidigen gilt sehr ger Damen und
Herren das sind am Ende des Tages wir
alle das sind wir beim Konzept der
umfassenden Landesverteidigung da sind
wir bei der geistigen Landesverteidigung
dass wir der nächsten Generation auch
wieder mitgeben müssen dass es nicht
selbstverständlich ist in einer
Demokratie in Frieden in Freiheit zu
leben und daher ist es wichtig dass wir
das auch wieder in den Lehrplänen
verankert haben der Schulen dass wir das
der nächsten Generation auch mitgeben
denn sehr geehrte Damen und Herren am
WHR Willen von uns allen an dem haben
wir auch für die Zukunft noch zu
arbeiten ich bitte Sie eindringlich tun
wir das auch zukünftig gemeinsam
miteinander gerade in diesen
herausfordernden Zeiten gehen sie den
Weg mit mit uns gehen sie den Weg mit
auf unserer Mission vorwärts zu einer
modernen Armee unterstützen Sie unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten auch weiterhin
die es die im Ernstfall auch ihr Leben
geben wenn es um die Verteidigung
unseres Landes geht danke
schön